awesome
how the mic works good morning it's so
wonderful to see
literally everybody in person
it's a close call and um yeah so in this
session
we're going to talk about building game
boy emulators and
well secretly the history of computing
and also secretly about failure and a
whole bunch of other stuff it's going to
be a bit of a wild ride so let me tell
you about myself a little bit so i'm
david and i'm an independent software
consultant based in london in the uk
now i work for myself which is wonderful
i would recommend it to everybody being
your own boss is the best
so i mostly mentor developers and i do
kind of strategic work for uk.com so
i've had a a wide range of really really
pretentious and pointless job titles
head of engineering chief technical
architect principal engineer blah blah
blah which all sounds a lot fancier than
it really really is i swear um
really i just love making things that's
the thing i really enjoy doing and i
love the people that make things
and i try and spend my time helping them
do that
i've
written a couple of kids books on
programming in javascript sorry
um getcoding2 and one available in all
your regional languages um and recently
i made a gameboy emulator
so
before we dive into
any of that i want to talk about what
emulation really is
emulation and it's very very technical
is the practice of specifically of
writing software on one system so it can
simulate the runtime environment of
another
with the goal of running software for a
different piece of hardware or
environment you've probably come across
this before right and there are a couple
of different broad approaches to
emulation
now there's low level emulation
and what that is is where you implement
the behavior of the raw hardware and
then the software designed for it should
just kind of work
and then we have high level emulation
where you attempt to run software
natively on your target platform and you
intercept the system calls of the
original
piece of software and re-implement them
in something more native now
most game emulators actually are a mix
and match of those two things
often what they do is they emulate
low-level hardware architecture while
re-implementing high-level things stuff
like 3d drawing calls are a great
example of where they can shortcut and
be really performant
and they do that in modern apis so there
are loads of really famous emulators
from kind of games console emulators to
operating system emulators so hardware
emulators so if you've ever run any kind
of vm you're running an emulator right
so when i say i built a game boy
emulator what i'm really saying
specifically is i built a program that
can run game boy software while the game
boy software itself believes it's
running on game boy hardware
which is a bit of a mouthful but it's
important but precise about these things
so why would you ever do that
um
it's all a bit pointless really honestly
but that's the fun of experimentation
that is the point
um there's lots of different answers to
this question but firstly i really just
wanted to see if i could do it
simple as that and so often
we are forced to live in this kind of
brutalistic corporate hellscape where
only things that have to exist for money
ever get rendered into reality right
so this is literally the opposite of
that thing game boy emulators totally
totally exist
like if you want to play game boy games
on your computer
i'm going to open up now but please
don't use my emulator don't do it please
don't do it it's incomplete it's
possibly buggy and i'm not going to help
you wake the wind fish and link's
awakening
this story is actually a little bit
different
and actually starts in the 70s
before i was born thank you um and it
starts with pong and it starts with an
interpreted language called chip 8.
so we're going to use it to understand
what emulation really is before we talk
about game boys and super
mario
sounds delicious right
um so i'd started toying around with
emulators as part of what i suppose now
is this decade-long experiment and
running coding dojos
so i do a lot of training for teams and
especially web dev teams
looking to upskill or pick up things
like tdd
now while i was looking for different
puzzles to set people in dojos i'd
plundered the archives of the old
website ruby quiz and it's still online
and it's still actually excellent if
you're looking for kind of catches to do
to
to to get better at random stuff so they
used to run weekly programming puzzles
and i ended up running the chip 8 cata
from there quite a few times it's ruby
quiz 88 if anyone's curious
so the the chip a cata provides a binary
program written in chip 8 which is a
machine language
and it tasks you with writing an
interpreter for it along with outlining
the hardware that the program runs on
now chip 8 has 32 op codes in total
but the program supplied by the quiz
only uses like a small subset of them to
make it a little bit more approachable
if you've never thought doing emulation
before
i remember thinking it sounded
absolutely terrifying the first time i
read it it's that you want me to
to write a
decompiler
what
yeah so that was i think everybody's
response when they see it so okay
firstly like opcodes machine languages
what
so
let's look at a quick example of how
computers and specifically our computer
processors our cpus work
before we go any further so when
processors are manufactured and you'll
have heard all these words before being
technical people but again understanding
what they really mean is very specific
especially if you don't have a computer
science background
they're manufactured and they they
implement a specific instruction set
now this this instruction set is
literally just the list of things that a
processor can do
now anyone old enough to you know might
remember the 1990s competition between
sisk and risk architectures
which stood for complex instruction set
and reduced instruction set computing
respectively
now these cpu instructions were what
they were using
when they said complex or reduced that's
what they were referring to
now the instructions themselves are
built into physical hardware and they
can be programmed using machine code
now every processor
family of processors really
has its own instruction set and as a
result it has its own machine code so
when people say things like they're
programming in assembly they're normally
referring to a specific kind of assembly
for a specific
piece of architecture
so machine code itself is a strictly
numerical representation
of all the operations that a processor
can perform
now an opcode shortened from operation
code
is the part of the machine code that
specifies what a cpu should do
mouthful again so the the assembly
language for a given processor can then
be assembled
hence the name into machine code
and is a low level abstraction over the
instruction set of your processor
now when we talk about assembly
languages what we really mean again is
programs written for a specific cpus
instruction set
so then the processor and hardware
implements those operations
it implements things like adding two
numbers or placing a number in memory at
a specific location
now the op code when a cpu is running a
program tells the cpu which instruction
to execute when it encounters it so i
appreciate this all sounds really really
abstract so let's look at this example
and we'll kind of try and understand it
so on the left you can see the raw
machine code of a chip 8 program that
we're going to come back to a few times
and that same machine code then
decompiled into its corresponding
instructions on the right
now besides the op code itself
most instructions also specify the data
they're going to process in the form of
what they call operands
now
honestly you can just think of them as
the parameters that are passed to the
opcode it's really really simple
and normally these parameters are just a
memory address or a register address the
register is just some memory that's on
the cpu itself
now a memory address is just a number
normally expressed in hexadecimal when
you see it written down
and they're just a number starting at
zero and counting up to however much
memory you have
now when people talk about how many bits
a cpu is what they're really referring
to is the largest number that the
computer can hold in memory when
expressed in hexadecimal
so literally the more more bits
the larger the total amount of memory a
cpu can address so we're starting to
build this picture of how hardware works
on the lowest possible level now
a cpu that only understands eight bit
numbers
like say the game boy
can only understand the numbers 0 to 255
as memory addresses
therefore it can address 256 memory
locations
subsequently a 16-bit processor can
understand the numbers zero to 6500
therefore it can address 65 536
um address locations
now literally the bigger the number the
more memory you got
now each memory location can then store
any amount of data depending on the the
implementation in the case of chip8
each memory address stores eight bytes
of data and the chip 8 hardware has 4
096 memory locations itself
so this is the foundation of all
computing i can like give you a computer
science third level third year degree
now i think this is basically it this is
what you went to university before
when when you use a higher level
programming language like c sharp or
javascript the runtimes execute those
programs have been compiled down for
your specific cpu architecture
this means that ultimately somewhere
something has been translated down to
machine code and is executing on your
cpu
and whenever you create variables in
your programs somewhere something is
putting things in memory registers for
you now it's all buried under loads and
loads of abstraction
and most memory manipulation is done by
interacting with the operating system
and and the operating system decides
what lives where in memory and this
process kind of happens transparently
for every single line of code you ever
write
so
after our crash course in like how
computers work
let's take a look at a chip 8 program
again how some of its op codes actually
function
now
the program in the the top left portion
of this slide is the original ruby quiz
chip 8 test program
it's just a raw binary file
in the machine language of the chip 8
computer now when you open it in a hex
editor that's literally a screenshot
what it looks like i think that was vs
code so to interpret this program what
you do is you loop through each of the
bytes and if you take a look at the
snippet of c
i've thrown in the slide as well there
we're we're just loading this file as a
byte array and like printing it out on
the screen so in c-sharp the bytes are
all represented in base 10 so as
integers
and um
when you look really carefully you
notice how the first number gets printed
as the number 97 which is 0x 61 in
hexadecimal
now if you look at the first two digits
of the original program at the top this
is the same 61 from the very start of
our test program so you can see how we
can chunk through these bytes
so our documentation shows that our chip
8 interpreter operates on two byte
operands so to run this program you need
to loop through each pair of bytes in
the binary blob in this case reading the
61 and the 77 together and then you
process them according to whatever the
hardware behavior is meant to be for
that op code
so if we zoom really really in on that
first two bytes in our file
we've got two hex numbers 6177 the make
up the op code and then it's operand now
this is expressed in the documentation
as
six x k k
now this this is explained in the quiz
as an op code that sets memory location
x to the constant value k k
so 6 1 7 7.
now if k k is an 8 bit constant
literally the hexadecimal value 77 or
to humans our first op code says six
do something
a constant one the memory address one
and seventy seven the decimal number 119
which translates to put
77 into memory location 1.
so if you imagine memory locations like
a big array or like an excel spreadsheet
or something
you can interpret the entire chip 8
program
by implementing each one of those
opcodes and writing code to perform the
logic with different op codes like six
in this case doing different things
you know it's it's a switch statement
now
it's a really scary looking problem
like really really really terrifying but
it's not really very complicated when
you break it down into it's really
really small pieces just a switch
statement
so the cool thing about this is because
it's so far out from what people
normally find themselves working on
you know people attending these dojos
always found it exciting when they made
progress because when you know you take
someone whose job is getting a number
from a database and putting on a web
page that's me that's basically all the
work i ever do
and then show them that the same skills
that they have that lets them do that in
a nice way is the same thing they can do
really really cool things with they get
really excited right it's fun
so i ended up running this dojo a lot
with plenty of different audiences
and i think there's nothing more fun
than
than doing this right showing them how
showing people how capable they are with
a bit of lateral thinking
and the programming doesn't have to be
like a blunt commercial only thing that
we just do to get paid
it can be fun
enjoyable intellectually challenging
the end
uh notes
so
now you know how to write an emulator
end of demo right
now let's talk about game boys
so chip hate is a useful introduction to
this kind of low level programming
because there are only 32 op codes in
total
and you know the ruby quiz cutter i
think uses 10 of them so give it a crack
like honestly it's great
i think it's important to remember
literally anyone can do things like this
and i'm not a particularly incredible
programmer i shouldn't say that on stage
with cameras running um
but i can read and reason
and i really wanted to know i've given a
background in building these smaller
scale emulators that i could do
something bigger
and game boys
what's a game boy
asked literally nobody ever everyone
knows what the gameboy is
a game boy more specifically is an 8-bit
handheld game console developed and
manufactured by nintendo
the first handheld in the game boy
family it was first released in japan on
april 21st 1989 in north america three
months later and lastly in europe a year
later it was designed by the same team
that developed the game and watch that's
why it's a game boy and several nintendo
entertainment system games thank you
wikipedia um i mean we all know what a
game boy is they're like literally
iconic you can set them on fire and they
still work i have literally seen this
happen
um they saw off about 50 billion
competitor consoles by being simple
accessible resilient and fun
and you know what this is this is my
childhood like legitimately it's deeply
personal to me is it my childhood in a
little plastic mold it's where my
lifelong obsession with video games came
from you know i literally typoed game
from in my notes
when i was when i was writing this um
game boys are awesome
and personally you know i grew up in
asia in the 1980s and i remember getting
a game boy from the temple street night
market in hong kong and i was always
excited because we go walking down you
know the night market streets and they
always had these game stores with
colorful boxes
stacked up in the windows and it really
like it really stuck with me
so not only is it awesome it's just as
personal right
we don't care where you bought your game
boy i can hear you all thinking
what is a game boy
all right don't ask the same question
twice it's rude
a game boy has an 8-bit 4.19 megahertz
cpu
8 kilobytes of ram and a 160 by 144
pixel display
the cpu is similar to an older intel
8080 cpu and most of the assemblers for
it use z80 syntax it's a custom chip but
the instructions are based on very very
well-known hardware
now i read those technical specs that i
felt emboldened
i'm gonna say that it's just like the
z80 it's like well old
how hard can this possibly be
um i had door games and i always have
and i love the 90s and 2000s emulation
porting scene but a few things
specifically sent me down this
particular path now i watch this great
youtube video on a channel called mvg
modern vintage gamer i don't know if
anyone's seen it he's a big deal on the
internet
and he did a time lapse of importing the
game another world to the original xbox
which i thought that's pretty cool um
and i spent some time the past couple of
years transliterating software for
clients so i'd been porting python and
java things into dotnet and.net core
and ironically porting.net core and
c-sharp stuff into typescript and
javascript
so i felt quite confident
transliterating code and i've been
working on some c and c plus plus
hardware projects
around building kind of displays and
stuff as well
and i thought hey
dead 80 processor isn't too different
from chip 8
in complexity absolutely not true
um i wonder if i can write a lo-fi game
boy emulator that could be used like
capture frames and send it to some kind
of hardware
that'd be really cool
um so i fell down this black hole of
here are pdfs about reverse engineering
the game boy hardware and you know those
like wikipedia holes that you fall into
sometimes this is like really deep
really really deep
like the 90s were wild
so i spent about a day reading this
thing called pens docs
which is a 25-year long community effort
to catalog all the details of game boy
hardware
like this is like peak 1990s era deep
technical unpacking and reverse
engineering of game boy hardware it's
like a head full really really really is
they're wonderful documentation i would
not recommend them as a casual bedtime
read um no plot the characters are
boring
so i skipped to what i felt was the most
interesting place to start looking to
like read some information from
cartridges
um
i opened visual studio and i started to
code
so
while from the frame of reference of
writing an entire emulator passing a
cartridge might not seem like that much
of a big deal i got it done pretty
quickly like we're talking a couple of
hours
so i grabbed my copy of totally legally
backed up nintendo please please don't
sue me i swear um super mario land
um which i happen to have on my computer
as a rom
and uh actually i still actually have my
copy of super mario land that i got when
i was a kid so this is probably actually
the most legal thing i've ever done and
i managed to pass the boot logo
the cartridge information and the
metadata within a few hours of hacking
around you literally pass the byte
stream from the top of the rom kind of
interesting
and it felt real and exciting like i had
some virtual memory i had a class called
cpu and i had some op codes and it was
starting to tick
super super cool
and then i got stuck
like really really really stuck
um i felt like i had a reasonable grasp
of the gameboy hardware
but i couldn't understand why some of my
op codes
what they were meant to do i was reading
the docs and i just i couldn't work out
what they were doing and my emulator
kept on crashing in the boot sequence
now to make matters even more confusing
the documentation had started to use
notation that i didn't understand
now
i'm not sure if it's some fairly
standard high school maths thing but i
am not a maths person
and um it was really boiling my brain i
didn't understand the notation
i was trying to implement the op codes
for the gameboy cpu just like in the
earlier chip 8 example as a glorified
switch statement and i just kept getting
lost
now not to be deterred i went hunting
for some other code bases that had been
here before in an attempt to find
something that could at least help me
understand the notation in the
documentation
now
i found a couple of emulators that
worked in a couple of different
languages and i stumbled across the
coffee gb project
and it was a working emulator in java
1.8 you um i i just um it was wonderful
literally wonderful a cloneable
repository that would build when i
checked it out that i could reason about
in the language i understood like how
often do you find that in open source
projects
all my christmases at once
um
so what i figured is i could try
transliterating this mit license code
base
and use some of the open source test
suites that were in that code base to
kind of glue things together at the end
and work out what i was getting wrong
so
because we all like to shave the yaks i
started off by losing the entire day
converting coffee gb to kotlin because i
thought oh kotlin would be closer to c
sharp and it'd be easier to understand
um like it worked like i do have a weird
nascent port of it in kotlin but there's
no point in that thing existing
um
so before deciding to commit and i did a
like for like transliteration of the
whole java source code across internet
core 3.1 in an attempt to hopefully
understand when my own op code
processing was was going wrong
yeah i keep on saying transliterate
let's talk about that really really
specifically
um this is originally a language term
meaning very very specifically to write
or print a letter or word
using the closest corresponding letters
of a different alphabetical script
so for a little clarification a
transliteration as opposed to just a
port just a port is a line for line
cosmetic only change
now
you change the absolute minimum code
required to get the software compiling
in the target environment
and then do subsequent second and third
passes to port things that are missing
or don't really convert like to like for
like
so porting and transliterating software
is a very very specific discipline
which is counter to how i and probably
all of you would build software normally
there are these three passes
so
firstly you transliterate it until it
compiles so you start at the entry point
and you work your way down
now this normally involves starting at
the main method and only migrating code
that gets called file by file
and then secondly you port over any test
suite once the transliteration is done
and ensure that the tests match the
original
once you're in that place of safely you
convert the code to be idiomatic in the
target language and you have to be
really disciplined about sticking to
those exact three phases to make sure
you don't introduce errors
now in the above examples you can see
how the java is subtly changed into
c-sharp
with package declarations swapped for
namespaces and attributes being removed
now later much of that syntax is is
converted to c sharp eight so we're
using expression bodied methods that
obviously don't exist in java
and then you know this is a fairly trite
and succinct example just to fit on some
slides but some of the conversions are
far more dramatic in fact
so you might think this is a set of
obvious steps but you end up doing some
really really unnatural things to the
code base that often totally go against
your instincts now during the first
phase especially you often find yourself
fighting your tools because you're at a
disadvantage if you diverge in any way
from the original source code to prevent
comparisons
now this means you have to do horrible
things like keep the naming conventions
and casings and odd non-idiomatic
qualities of the foreign code base right
precisely as they are until you're at a
point of safety
now you also have to get very very
comfortable with throwing not
implemented exceptions like literally
everywhere
so especially where a direct equivalent
is not available and you've managed to
get the co until you've managed to get
the code executing
now the sooner you get to a place where
you can start translating the available
tests the better
because you'll know early on if you're
going off track right so you kind of
want to get compiling you want to get
tests compiling and you want them all
failing and then you can chip away and
chip away
so ideally to do this you need a good
reading grasp of the source language and
like a relatively advanced grasp of the
target language that you're porting to
in an attempt to convert some of the
more subtle differences
so in this particular code base for
example java has really rich enums which
often have behavior loaded into them
which we totally don't have in c sharp
right in c sharp they're just integers
now
producing similar syntactic constructs
that could be used in the same way is
quite important so you kind of require a
reasonable mastery of of the target
language to pull that off without
getting yourself
stuck with a non-compiling code base so
you have to do things like when you're
porting enums build extension method on
the enum values that you can call to
replicate that kind of java-like
behavior and apis
so
once i found my groove transliterating
the coffee gb code base a couple of
things became apparent
so firstly the ui was just never going
to port
absolutely wasn't going to port not
trivially um it was a bunch of java jwt
code and i don't know if anyone else
remembers the 1990s um
but that's where i think the last person
that thought about jwt code still is
there was no point in trying to convert
that like for like i wasn't going to
port java windowing toolkit to c-sharp
like there's the shaving yaks and like
importing your own herd of yaks to shave
one by one
the jwt code however slightly annoyingly
was responsible for both drawing the
game to the screen and handling
controller inputs in the the source
emulator
fine write it down another thing to do
so my first target quickly became to get
the headless mode in the original
codebase booting a gameboy cartridge
now headless mode was designed to run
the emulator without visual output
controls in a console window
i figured if i could do enough to just
get that running i could port the unit
test to exercise some of the community
authored homebrew roms and there's a set
of roms are designed to test various
aspects of the gameboy hardware to make
sure your emulators are working
correctly
so i deleted all the jwt code
i left all the stubs of the codepets and
the function calls in place just
replacing their bodies with not
implemented exceptions
and i implemented a few interfaces with
empty implementations
and i managed to cajole headless mode
into life
so you can see the the code for headless
mode as it still exists today in the
source code here
i'm passing in null displays and null
controllers and null sound and null
inputs
along with amusingly the remnants of
some of the jwt code left commented out
for reference but in case i need to look
up what it did
and you know what like
i cannot state enough
how well compartmentalized the original
code base was
like honestly
properly kudos to the original author i
was very very lucky
that when it came to writing a new
display
the original code
kept an array of pixel colors packed
into an integer
and the various graphics op codes
produced those and they actually
resulted in this pixel array so all i
really had to do to get stuff on screen
was convert that array of packed
integers into x y coordinates and find a
way to like quickly
quickly get out on the screen right
so i extracted these rgb values and um
and i raised a c sharp event every time
they changed
and i created this new bitmap display
class
and so to match the original
implementation my display class runs on
its own thread refreshing distinctly
from the cpu so i've kind of got my cpu
ticking and emitting events and then a
bitmap display class listening to them
and
needing to do something right i just
need something
to draw some pixels um
anyone done any desktop programming
in net recently and knows how diverse
the uh
and possibly not well maintained the set
things up well you know what i nailed it
one forms
i'm not even joking
um
you heard me right i ported the gameboy
emulator.net core 3.1 just to run it in
a wim forms ui and i'm not sorry i'd do
it again
the number of questions i got about this
re
my sanity uh re why i wasn't running wpf
if anyone still used wim forms if
winforms random.net core was quite
excellent
people forget that wim forms was
designed to be easy to use for rapid
application development
and it kind of lets you get stuff on the
screen really really quickly and
computers are fast now so it's fine
um wim forms is actually secretly kind
of awesome and it does run.net core now
five and six only on windows obviously
because winforms on the mac
doesn't make any sense
and it just works
so about 200 lines of code later i had a
wim forms ui with a picture box on it
that i could update every time my game
boy emulator raised an event
and um if you're eagle-eyed and look
closely at the background images here
you'll notice another nice thing that
came free from wim forms
input handling just like the original
jwt code base
so i could hook an implementation of a
controller class up to the winforms
window window key press events and it
just worked
like i think i hacked this together in
about 45 minutes
and i sat there thinking that everyone
was going to judge me incredibly harshly
but i was unrepentant
and and it worked
like legit it worked kind of um kind of
so once i got to this point where i had
the title screen of mario booting in c
sharp and side by side the original java
code base booting the same game
i realized that i'd made some kind of
terrible terrible error
um
where every time i press start the game
would crash
and
yeah obviously enough of my port was
working like i'd got somewhere i had a
screen
but um but establishing where my code
had diverged from the original
definitely working code base
was a terrifying prospect
but luckily i am not the first person to
ever try and write a game boy emulator
right so we go back to the internet in
the face of our own failures
so there's a really good set of home
brew test roms that exercise the game
boy hardware that i mentioned earlier
now
what i wanted to do is i wanted to run
the test roms in both emulators side by
side and see where they diverge
they're wonderfully named one of them is
called blog and the other is the moon
eye test roms
i think the latter is actually from a
work in progress rust emulator i don't
know where people make up these names
fine
so i ported the test harness across to
the original code base and i got the
test runs running and just as i
suspected tests that were passing in the
java code base were failing in my port
this was a great first
step really i had failing tests and i
hope everyone understands the value of a
failing test when something isn't
working
i just needed to find out what exactly
i've broken and you know i ported
i don't know 5000 lines of code
now
these are both low-level emulators at
this point and it's important to
understand this so they literally
implement the op codes of the hardware
and they tick at the clock rate of the
cpu so 4.19 megahertz
doesn't sound like a lot of megahertz
for
until it's a loop
like thousands and thousands and
thousands of iterations of cpu ticks a
second
now you can't meaningfully step through
the code because the number of
operations they have to complete to see
any change in memory is like
a lot a lot
thousands and thousands of steps
but that's okay
we live in visual studio right we have
tools that are good
um
we have things like conditional break
points
i felt emboldened i can just put a
conditional breakpoint in this thing and
you know when when a value changes that
i don't expect in memory
cool break into a a debugger
so ironically
the performance overhead of applying a
conditional break point to one of my
virtual cpu registers was so
severe that i couldn't even get visual
studio to process a single test case as
far as the first era in like less than
10 minutes on like a ryzen 5950x
right it just it literally couldn't run
fast enough with that instrumentation in
place
um
so i knew that i had to get both code
bases into a point where i had a break
point where memory state diverged right
that was the goal
and i could solve the problem i was
seeing if i could do that i just wasn't
really immediately sure how so
you may all recognize this from your
regular jobs as
your integration tests being your only
tests right it's always a bad place when
your integration tests your only tests
because you know something is broken
just not where
so i ended up spending a morning
building two tools
i started by building a debugging tool
and i built a client in both java and
c-sharp that keeps the ticks of the
emulators in sync
breaking them both into the debugger
when they their memory state diff
through doing like a hash of the memory
both emulators would call a http server
with a hash of their current memory
state and where it differed it would
make them pause right it seems like i
can see you can see where this is going
right
which is a great idea in theory um but i
just mentioned that conditional
breakpoints were slow
yeah not very smart sometimes
it worked
i i didn't get there with it because it
was so slow right um
there was way too much overhead like it
helped me find like one bug which was
cool and i fixed it and it did kind of
pay off for the sake of a morning's
effort
but too much overhead so i had to go low
five a bit of logging function into each
emulator that i could wrap around the
test cases that just dumps the memory
state to a massive text file on every
cpu tick
right so i i left it running for half an
hour right
and i knew that when the test passed in
the first emulator the one in the other
one should have passed and i could stop
it
old tricks of the best tricks
and so so what happened is i did these
lengthy diffs on like multi-gigabyte
long log files we're talking 10 20 gig
long log files like 20 seconds of
execution
um
to find the tick number where the
emulators diverged and it worked so once
i had a tick number i just added a
debugger break into the code wrapped in
an if statement
if tick
is 29 000 whatever debugger break
perfect
um
and well i added at the immediate tick
before so i could then step through
execution and
it was important that i kept those two
transliterated code bases so close
because actually when the test cases
passed or failed equally i could pretty
much look at the same line number of
code and just step through side by side
if i diverge them by this point
debugging would have been a nightmare
honestly i would have probably given up
so the first bug that i fixed this way
felt a little bit like magic
like i felt like i'd pulled off the
heist of the century like just their
sense of accomplishment like did you
actually just build your own debugging
tools and it worked
yes
go me
it took about a day a day of doing this
but i got my emulator in parity with the
original coffee gb source and i could
start refactoring at that point like it
was it was in a good place
so what was the crashing bug
for the sake of argument
so i had fallen foul of converting one
of the java data structures to c sharp
now as i mentioned earlier in java enums
can have methods
and i'd hastily transliterated some code
that categorized enums for different
banks of memory in the game boy now
you'll notice if you glance to the top
right here that the enum names are used
to categorize different parts of the
same type of memory
so for instance and it's a little bit
fuzzy so rom underscore mbc 3
and rom underscore mbc 3 ram
are both identifying parts of the memory
that make up mbc 3 so that stands for
memory bank controller 3. it's part of
the game boy cartridge physically so the
way that game boy cartridges work
is they have memory banks to expand the
amount of memory available to games
which gets switched out dynamically by
some op codes
um
that's why just coincidentally that in
the 90s when they advertise game boy
games the sizes of cartridges were used
in marketing material like oh it's a
four megabyte cartridge right and it's
because they use that memory basically
for graphics all the time it was just
restoring sprite data so the bigger the
megs the more graphics the nicer the
game tended to look and it was because
they had more expensive
multiple memory banks they were
switching out
so the code in the emulator that
implemented the opcode to switch these
memory banks needed to check if the
current memory bank location was part of
one of these memory banks now the
original java implementation used a
regular expression to check the name of
the enum member
so it basically checked if it just
contained the name of the memory bank it
was looking for
now i had hastily replaced that regular
expression with a string contains call
and the presumed that the enum member
would always have an underscore followed
by mbc something followed by an
underscore
which works perfectly well for the
string rom underscore mbc 3 underscore
ram two underscores but not so well for
rom underscore nbc3
oops
oops we are all fallible
so while trying to switch memory banks
my code was just failing and quickly
replacing that string contains method
with the original regular expression
just fixed the bug right
um you know i know there are way more
idiomatic c-sharp ways to do this like
you can mark them up with attributes or
god knows what um
but it worked honestly fine like don't
don't sweat the small stuff right
so one of the final entertaining
surprises was the afternoon i lost
trying to find out why my emulator was
slow
so on a related note you'd be surprised
what a difference the release builds
make
it's like a list of basic c sharp
mistakes
um yeah i spent what felt like an
eternity trying to profile the
performance of the emulator because i
just couldn't work out why it was
performing so slow and so badly
and it was just because it was being
observed
oops so the program was just ticking so
fast that the overhead of collecting
metrics and debugging instrumentation
just slowed the program down so simply
compiling and running in release mode
without a debugger attached totally
matched the performance of the original
emulator which was also
running in a release build without a
debugger attached right totally fine
i've also perhaps
skirted around the issue of audio in the
emulator because there is no audio
um
i've not written it because i don't know
how
uh
i've never done audio programming before
and i'm looking into various audio
wrappers i know there's like n audio and
i'll try and work out how to make tetra
sing
it's just a slow process learning things
you really don't know
and
it worked you know throughout the first
couple of weeks of this project
and given we were all we were all in
quarantine at the time this was
happening right this was a this is a
peak lock down
stop me going insane project um
i've been teasing the internet with
screenshots of game boy games and things
like that so once i got to the point
where the ui wasn't crashing and the
code was suitably ported i just chucked
the the emulator on github you know
mostly for the fun of it
and generally people have enjoyed seeing
this kind of project done in c-sharp
rather than yet another business
application there's an acronym that's
going around at the moment like a
blobbum or something like a boring line
of business application i just wanted
something that wasn't there
and oh yeah i stuck a ridiculous ascii
art renderer on the front of it so you
can play super mario and ascii art on
the command line
everyone's
bucket list item right totally um why
would you not want that and and really
that was the reason for doing this at
all and that's kind of the point i
really want to make
you know c-sharp is a language i love
and i feel very comfortable with
i love the direction that.net core56
plus is going and i'm on a bit of a
journey at the moment trying to prove
that we're really a place with net
where it can really do anything any
other runtime or language can do at
least as performantly and often plenty
more beautifully in code right like i
really i truly believe that
and it's wonderful to see other people
like engaging with it in good faith and
you know
seeing the same thing you know
interestingly after i put this online um
i got message from a guy who used it for
like a twitter plays pokemon thing where
he used the back end for this to update
his user picture and people could tweet
controls at him and they played the way
through pokemon
um
yeah it was awesome right um though
needless to say it wasn't without its
distractors
so you know everyone always says never
read the comments shall we read some of
the comments together
it's gonna be good i always like to
engage
um and there was one comment that both
stuck with me and uh i thought was
important enough to highlight
so let's let's make a stranger from
reddit famous for a moment
oh
god code quality is questionable here's
how the author emits frames they create
a new image
big fat allocation that be like i don't
know my hip-hop name um iterate over
every pixel convert its value to a
string and immediately pass it back as a
source for an rgb color and fill a
single pixel with it create a memory
stream without god he just kind of went
big fat allocation another big fat
allocation
call tour
just look at this crap right
some electron level resource wasting he
probably says while visual studio code
and slack are open on his desktop
oh jesus christ read it as ever is a
mixed bag
so i had a bunch of really interesting
conversations with people in the dot-net
and c-sharp subreddits
the general programming subreddits on
the other hand not so much
um it's easy to forget how hostile
people compete absolutely nothing at all
and legitimately one of the takeaways of
this process for me was this
as programmers we can be short we can be
snipey we can dig through code
contextless and take swipes at things
just to bring each other down right
everything in that comment 100 true
i could totally be better
but you know what
the program consumes between 30 and 50
megabytes of ram in total i benchmarked
it
and i do it all again in a heartbeat to
put out something cool and interesting
in the world that people got a little
bit of joy from
loud and clear no gatekeepers
no perfection
doesn't exist
do the fun thing
enjoy yourselves
share stuff otherwise balls like that
win
right and absolutely i don't want to
live in a world with those people
like my god
luckily the boys never win in face of
you doing cool stuff honestly so within
a day or two of pushing out some tweets
with links to the code i had a couple of
pull requests
um one with the mono game ui that let
the emulator run on various devices
one with an avalonia ui that let the
emulator run on linux and mac as well as
the existing winforms ui cross-platform
headless cli with its ascii art
you know like
you can reference the game boy
emulator as a library in your programs i
don't know why you would ever do that or
what use it would be but you could do it
if you want to
and you know the the the twitch the
twitter place pokemon thing you know
scott hanselman wrote a blog post about
it where he was hacking some code in it
like it's fun people like fun
why do people hate
fun um you know i'm very happy and the
you know the lesson for me for this and
the lesson i want to leave everybody
with is you know don't give up when you
get stuck
you know i know it sounds really really
trite but everything we do in software
is built on the shoulders of other
talented people that build things before
us and it's easy to get stuck and it's
easy to give up
and it's hard to go and decide to look
around for inspiration you know i'm
super super thankful for the wonderfully
high quality coffee gb co-base like i
made a snide jabbed it being java 1.8
but it was a brilliant code base like
legitimately brilliant code base
i had the pleasure of adapting it i had
the pleasure of merging it with my own
work and my own efforts
you know i'm happy i didn't actually
succumb to my own hubris and decide that
if i couldn't just work it out on my own
then it wasn't worth doing
um you know i'm absolutely thrilled that
by sacrificing that little bit of ego
there's something cool and fun that
people can play with
and i hope you know i hope if you get
the chance have some fun with it like
trash the place it's cool i'm excited
you can find me on the internet in all
these places
feel free to tweet at me harass me buy
my books
don't reddit me
um i promise i don't bite thank you so
much for coming
[Applause]
really thank you there's a whole room
here
any questions
i probably can't answer them but
i'm happy to try
no
two and a half weeks
from the first idea
i say that i always misrepresent the
amount of time
um what it really was was a month of me
sleeping on the idea
and then a morning of waking up and
going ah i can probably do that let's
start
and you know what like we're all locked
down and i i was in this this place
where i'd i
i quit all my jobs all my client
engagements on the 1st of february 2020
to go traveling
to do some conferences i had like a
wedding booked in south africa i had a
trip to new york like three conferences
so that lasted like three weeks
um and i needed to fill up the rest of
my year so i did like 14 weird projects
in a year just to see what weird stuff i
could do
because it was my own time
so yeah it was about a month of stewing
and then
two and a half weeks of hacking hacking
hacking head down
excuse me
any more for any more
amazing thank you so so much and um have
enjoy the rest of your day like thank
you to the organizers this has been a
labor of love in the face of all
adversity
[Applause]
you